Food. You know, I just couldn't stop thinking about it.
Yeah?
So, yeah.
So, you know, I went to the fridge and I opened up the meat drawer.
You know what the meat drawer is, right?
Yeah, what was in there?
Well, I'll tell you what was in there.
You know that bacon that's like maple?
It's got maple flavor.
The maple kind, yeah.
Yeah so,...
Yeah.
...I took that out and I thought...
Yeah?
...I know who would like that.
Me! So, I ate it.
No, you're kiddin' me.
Nope. Not kiddin'.
You know, I also noticed there were some beef in there.
Yeah, you know, steak.
You know, juicy.
Well, I ate that too.
But I went back to the fridge, just a few minutes ago.
And I put something together really special.
You're gonna love this one.
I took some chicken,...
Yeah?
...yeah, I put some cheese on it.
Then, I covered it with...
Covered it with what?
...covered it with cat treats.
Yeah.
Then guess what?
What?
I gave it to the cat!